The Joe Rogan Experience there will be
no like Secrets within 20 years there
would be zero secrets of anything in
your mind you won't even be able to keep
thought secret within 20 years right
because they they'll figure out a way
just to like read just to do it man just
to know what the neural energy is inside
of your brain pick it up yeah and then
translate it anyone driving by people
that's oh my God it's coming that tin
foil that's when truly people are gonna
have to start wearing stupid helmets
imagine if that's what really works it's
not tin foil but it's one of those um
what are those things called the uh
you put your phone into and then a
faraday cage yeah it's like a faraday
cage so there it is a tin foil hat
instead of a tin foil hat it's a faraday
hat and when you see someone wearing it
you're like there goes a liar look at
them with their [ __ ] Liars helmet on
they have to wear that so we don't know
what they're really thinking but what if
the hackers get a hold of that and make
like influential programs that go into
your [ __ ] memories and and change
memories like well we have these digital
memories but we also have filters shut
the [ __ ] up someone already made one of
these this is the best day of their life
by the way Faraday cap oh my God they
have one Lamb's Faraday cap wave stopper
technology 99 UV and wireless radiation
why do I think it's hot that she would
believe that
right a pretty girl that has a faraday
hat on that's cool like yeah she's so
crazy she believes the government's
trying to wire it I like it it's [ __ ]
cool yeah now it's better that's like a
little red wine I love that oh this is
on uh Amazon it's only 60 bucks wow Fair
radiation protection I'm gonna wear that
on stage from now on that's my new look
yeah but what happens you start wearing
that podcast we're wearing those and our
and all of a sudden we're ordering dose
please
we're way more articulate imagine like
our thoughts clear up what if all of a
sudden you just feel more relaxed and
you realize oh my God it's electronic
interception
okay it's [ __ ] up bees yeah you know
they think cell phone signals are
[ __ ] bees up yeah because I think
it's like a constant Jackhammer
they're like whoa like this [ __ ] is not
supposed to be out here they're supposed
to be out communicating somehow or
another they don't exactly know
that's so creepy man that's so sad I I
what's so funny
I'd say it there's a beanie a beanie why
is that so funny
you just thought it was that funny
yeah
Jamie did you get a contact we know
there's a Temple where is it oh all the
time they would get Temple a new Beanie
maybe against 5G cell towers smart
meters and Wi-Fi maybe that's what uh
maybe he's ahead of the game keep your
family protected you should keep your
family protected get your [ __ ] kids
to wear beanies yeah man oh we got to
get a beanie well we should definitely
get a hood well why don't you start
making them JRE Faraday cat cages it's
called a very Touch and Go rain coat oh
nice good night shielding for your mind
you're a knight in the digital War there
you go oh that's a faraday cage that's
oh for hunting that way I could really
be one with nature without any influence
and look you can keep your phone in that
pocket right near your ear
that earmuff looks like a cell phone
pocket that's the only pocket just just
answer your phone from right there hello
Duncan speaking there's like a little
hole where the microphone is at the
bottom oh God I love it man I I I'm
actually there's a whole industry out
there for these things of course that's
pretty fascinating let's get ready for
Faraday cage underwear because I know
those are out there too yeah right I
mean that makes more sense to me a dick
sheath something to keep your the EMF
off your dick yeah like a jock strap
like some kind of a harness 100 that
makes more sense in the hell they have
it there they go there you go it's
already there where do we got here all
of it those are Faraday cage yup Faraday
underwear Ferris that's you give that to
your girl so baby it's the same company
Lambs they're all over it
that's crazy man you said baby this
[ __ ] can't be on an open network we
gotta close you today
cage over that [ __ ]
anti-radiation underwear anti-radiation
under all that I mean I don't know if
that's a bad idea is it testicular
cancer survivor I think it's a good idea
do you think that the the radiation that
you get from cell phones gives people
cancer or could I don't know don't
answer that because we're on a podcast
what do you mean we don't know I'm like
don't answer that what I would it's a
terrible question to answer oh you but
you I think you're allowed to go I don't
know and then say maybe it's this right
like we don't clearly we don't know I
don't know but I know that like before I
got testicular cancer I played a lot of
[ __ ] World of Warcraft on a laptop
right on my dick I know that oh Jesus
Christ is that what did it who knows but
I would imagine keeping like a powerful
thing that's radiating energy
over your balls is probably not the best
idea right that's not the best idea no
try to get a little separation there I
don't think that's crazy or anything